hey all I know is it's good having
another brother moving to the
neighborhood hey man it's good to have
you over and I'll take that you will dig
this
hey nice guitar collection
oh that's Manny you want to hear
something yeah sure
well I'm just a good old American boy
with a heart that's red buttons dreamin
of the girl with the red hair and
freckles in her eyes like the skies are
blue touch music I grew up in Texas you
know so alright keep her safe from the
home is in the wrong side of town where
they're smoking the reefer and acting
like clowns keep that pretty address
from getting dirty in Brown cuz that's
the American Way oh pretty racist song
racist against who of black people black
people man but I'm black well keeping
the redheaded girl away from the homies
on the wrong side of town homies come on
brother this is all kinds of homies
white homies Asian homies homies are
black know I think you're making them
black man I mean I think that's your
stuff you hear the twang and then you
assume that it's racist but that's
that's just what country music is like
look if you even like this you'll like
this one
alright
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
40 and their chicken deep-fried I think
we all know we're talking about the only
dark guy like us when I turn off the
lights the only hood I love this party
and Wyatt and trust you if I can't see
your face hey stop that that's racist
what's what what is race is about it the
only hood I love is pointy and white
yeah man let's talk about the Klan man
the Ku Klux Klan are you outside of your
mind that's traditional country music
imagery man like a pickup truck or
sleeping under the stars or your dog got
killed or your wife left you same thing
I would have been fine with any of those
things what is the difference between
those things and what is in the song
they're not racial hey you know what
kind of say something man I'm just gonna
be frank you're getting a little like Al
Sharpton like Farrakhan army right now
oh my god are you serious hey can you
you know what I do one more let me just
do one more dog I absolutely promise you
that this song is not racist and it's
impossible for you to misinterpret it as
such
okay it seems like you're about to sing
the most racist song so far
come on man hey Shh over here trying to
sing about a tire swing light off an
entire genre music the banjo strumming
and the drums are a banging let's get
the boys together and have ourselves a
hanging oh damn now I see it now I see
it
you